à propos de voitures encore une
innovation qui pourrait bien faire
fureur un nouveau signal anti radar à
brancher sur l'allume-cigare il ne
s'agit pas d'un détecteur ils sont
interdits mais d'une application de la
technologie gps
autrement dit c'est parfaitement légal
explications diego garcia et bling
godman d'abord il clignote cuisine bip
attention il ya un radar automatique
dans le secteur vous avez 20 secondes
pour ralentir et éviter le flash l'armé
absolue contre les amendes
peut-être le fabricant lui ne manque pas
d'arguments
c'est un outil de sécurité routière qui
assure une meilleure prévention est
effectivement sans la sanction
simple d'utilisation il suffit de le
brancher sur l'allume-cigare et de
rouler aujourd'hui il n'est
commercialisé que dans ce magasin de la
banlieue parisienne son prix 99 euros
c'est vrai que 90 euros c'est le prix
d'une amende une amende j'en ai eu une
ça me suffit maintenant je voudrais les
inviter alors que je roule jamais
spécialement vie on pense en vendre plus
de 1000 jusqu'à la fin de l'année
puisque effectivement il répond
complètement une demande aujourd'hui du
marché du consommateur en fait cet
avertisseur utilise la technique du gps
le système de positionnement par
satellite
il signale l'emplacement des radars
comme le font aussi les panneaux de la
sécurité routière
contrairement aux détecteurs ce système
ne brouillent pas le faisceau du radar
et c'est pour ça qu'il est légal
en tout cas si cette innovation est un
plus pour les automobilistes
elle a tout pour déplaire au
gouvernement c'est la sécurité absolue
par rapport aux radars automatiques et
ça malgré son discours sécuritaire je
crois que le gouvernement ne le veux pas
parce que quelque part il faut quand
même encore une fois amortir les
appareils que grâce à nos impôts mais
sur le bord des routes à grand coup de
millions d'euros un an après
l'installation des premiers radars
automatiques
près de deux millions de conducteurs ont
été verbalisés ce petit boîtier est sans
doute promis à un bel avenir